I never I'm having a scientific argument
with someone and I need your help I do
love a good science fight has it evolved
the name calling it yes I called him a
Pongo pygmaeus Oh a Bornean orangutan
that is a creature who would be very bad
at science well done I know so how can I
help
I posted a theory on the collapse of
wavefunction we've been arguing back and
forth and he's saying that my
probabilities come out negative have you
considered that negative probabilities
can still have meaning I hadn't that
suggests another idea I can argue that
negative probabilities only show up in
intermediate steps I'm gonna destroy him
with this and when you do feel free to
call him a scarab is VI a dung beetle oh
I so admired your mind back at your
little man
can I top off your coffee where it's
awfully nice of you
we know me I'm a pleaser just wanna know
what I talked about Dave not really I
promise you got nothing to worry about
it in same thing thank you so what'd you
find out about him
you damn straight that's how it works
now spill this see uh he likes to drink
likes to hunt he's got a son who's
divorced yeah I know all this go on
that's all I got are useless we'd come
to his senses and dumps you I'm gonna
stay friends with it good if he dumps me
he deserves to suffer
hey Dale hey George
so she's gonna be okay out there well I
talked the other coach boys are gonna
leave her alone hey Billy
you're supposed to be warming up they
want to coach a baseball team
you praying I'm asking the Lord to watch
over my little girl while you're at it
ask him for a win I got money on this
you bet on a kids baseball game I got
three to one odds
thanks to dr. Sturgis I had all the
intellectual ammunition I needed to
bring my opponent to his knees I accused
him of conflating two different
interpretations of quantum theory
woefully misrepresenting Paul Dirac and
when I called him a dung beetle in Latin
I was so gryal dup I almost started
producing testosterone has merit
[Music]
that day both my sister and I emerged
victorious from savage battles hers
fought with fists mine with words
[Applause]
but we were both pretty sore the next
day
[Music]